[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
in the next half hour or so then we will
see what's making the headlines
with the sun's political editor harry
cole and the political editor
of the daily mirror pippa crea great to
see both of you
so front pages then big day for news
obviously
the eye leading on the news of the delay
to so-called freedom day
with the lockdown set to continue for
another four weeks
that same story leads the metro which
says
freedom has been put on ice on the
hottest day of the year
and will we ever be free asks the sun
that's also on the front page of the
yorkshire post which says the delay is
due to concerns
over the spread of the delta variant the
guardian says the next four weeks will
be used to
vaccinate more people with younger
people also set to be offered the jab
the daily mail is concerned that boss
johnson was unable to guarantee that the
economy would
fully reopen come the 19th of july
the telegraph says there's a lack of
clarity on when
exactly the restrictions will end with a
picture there of anti-lockdown
protesters
while the financial times leads on the
disappointment felt by businesses
after boris johnson told them they would
get no further support
despite the delayed reopening so let's
get the thoughts then
of the sun's harry cole and the mirror's
pippa career
as predicted really by both of you last
monday uh this has happened
harry let's go to you first of all what
are your headlines from today
well look i thought there's a really
different boris johnson today
um if you would remember back to someone
like dominic cummings's evidence to
parliament a few weeks ago where
he lift the lid on the battles to go
back into lockdown last year
where it was a sort of evidence of
battling against everyone else and he
was you know putting
you know semi-arbitrary dates on things
saying it'll be done in 12 weeks it'll
be
done by christmas it'll be done by
easter and now here we are again
uh but um the prime minister did a void
i think it was the biggest thing for us
that was that
when actually asked you know is it
really gonna be july 19th he went i hope
so
but you know i'm not gonna make any
promises and it just shows you what that
15 months has done to boris johnson as a
politician as a leader
uh and as an expectation manager um and
frankly
um it was a hefty it was a hefty caveat
so
um we now get to do what we've been
doing for last month which is
trying to work out from scouring the
data seeing what's going on talking to
ministers and things working out whether
it really will be
july uh july or or whether it could
heaven forbid um slip into a into the
school summer holidays
yes i think my favorite was the daily
telegraph uh headline which was it's
definitely july the 19th unless it's not
which is the
most unusual telegraph headline i've
seen for a while um he did talk about
terminus day didn't he
on july the 19th and you wonder where
that confidence comes from
because the graph of cases goes up and
we saw professor chris witte
standing there saying make no mistake
the cases will continue to rise
but also we had pippa public health
england reporting today
fantastic news on two doses
and the risk of hospitalization that's
right they have done
um their research now in the findings
right today and they suggest that both
the pfizer
and the estrogenic jabs of more than 90
um effective when it comes to reducing
hospitalizations so obviously
that means they have a strong impact on
the seriousness
with which people are affected by covid
now that
is brilliant news because some of the
scientists suggested that
it might not be that high this is of
course after two
doses of the jab after one dose it's
it's quite substantially
lower so that really underlines how
important it is for people to get the
second jab
and and goes some way to explain how and
why the government has decided to speed
up the rollout
so we now have um by july the 19th
and this new target date um they want to
make sure that over 40s have had their
second jab that might mean
reducing the amount of time between
doses from 12 weeks to
eight weeks to make sure they can all be
done and to make sure that everybody
all adults have had their first dose
which although it doesn't offer a
complete protection
sort of sets them on the path to getting
that protection i mean
vaccines are still our way out of this i
think
i was quite um interested to see boris
johnson's slight change in tone today as
harry
referred to it but there was a lot of
mixed messages there still he can't help
himself
and i don't think it was so much
expectation management harry i think it
was more
that he can't bear to disappoint people
so by talking about the terminus state
um as at the same time he's saying well
he couldn't rule out
um the lockdown lifting being even later
than july the 19th
he was trying to give people some hope
and actually i don't think those mixed
messages
are particularly helpful not just to us
the general public but to all those
businesses who are obviously
still going to be severely impacted by
all of this yes or he might have the
likes of sigrin brady mark harper steve
baker
all of whom who ask questions of matt
hancock in the commons at
8 30 tonight ringing in his ears and
that's the problem isn't it there are
there's a wing at the tory party that
really don't want any of this go to the
daily mail for example
the prime minister the kerbs could go on
and on um you know
the right-wing press if i can describe
it so loosely is also of that vein
no i think there are lots of people you
know crying out for
for to be unshackled businesses
especially pubs this is meant to be a
glorious
summer of them with our hosting of the
euros but you know they are going to be
down you know
three billion pounds for this uh for
this delay um you know their views need
to be represented and listened to
but maybe you're right i do think there
is always been a slight um
inability to announce bad news without
some silver linings for the prime
minister and there were a couple today
um i think we can all probably discard
the idea of a a two
two week review clause um should things
go remarkably the other way
um by july the fifth but good news for
people that wanted to get married
outdoors a sort of tacit concession
really that outdoor mixing doesn't do
a huge amount of of spreading this
and capacity up for for wembley um
for four hour hosting of those euros as
i as i said and win wooden looks set to
be the first
um the first sporting event to have full
capacity for its final uh
in 15 months whether we'll get to that
stage remains to be seen
but crucially what they're waiting for
and it's not necessarily
all bad news is they just want the
definitive proof
that this you know that yes cases can go
up
and yes even hospitalizations might go
up does that translate into deaths
there was some real doomsday graphs
around from the medics from sage from
various other universities uh that were
presented to the stage today
that pointed that they could be go back
to those god awful days of 500 deaths
today
if this sort of if this if the breaks
aren't put on now
um whether or not the tory party will
put up with you know
that wing of the tory party you
mentioned will put up i think they can
live with four weeks i don't think they
can live with four months
that's interesting isn't it uh nor can
many businesses the point you were
making just there
if we go to the financial times they
quote the figure you used there
three billion cost in lost sales for
hospitality
uk hospitality the industry trade body
suggesting the new delay
would put 300 000 jobs at risk
while the ft points out the government
has already spent
407 billion on supporting companies
uh but many are concerned about the
tapering off of of some of these schemes
uh you know be it you know they want
more culture grants and they
you know the the rent holiday uh the
eviction moratorium not to mention the
furlough there's
a lot there's lots of things that that
the pressure is now on the
on the chancellor to look again at pippa
yes
and what the treasury have been saying
today and i suspect we'll hear more of
over coming days when the calls
intensify on them to do more businesses
that are going to be affected by this
delay
is that rishi senate factored into his
budget
um prospect of uh lockdown lifting not
going according to the road map as was
set out at the time
and so for example you have the furlough
scheme and various other schemes go on
till september
although as you rightly point out and as
the there's the tapering
which starts very soon and companies are
going to be asked to
contribute 10 initially um and into the
the fairly cost and then that'll
obviously go up
and if you're not if you have an income
as a company then that potentially is
going to be very difficult to do
so uh therefore potentially leading to
lots of job losses
and there are all sorts of other things
that as the ft points out that
the businesses want the government to do
such as small business grants
they want to wipe out some of those wipe
out some of those those loans these
bounce back loans which you'll remember
from
the beginning of the pandemic um they
want to extend full business rates to
relief
for companies in the sectors which are
worst hit by this so retail hospitality
and leisure um yet boys johnson was
quite clear today that there's not going
to be
any extension to any of those schemes i
think they will be under intense
pressure and it'd be interesting to see
as as if harry said as harry suggests if
it goes on
beyond these four weeks i think the
government may have to think again on
that
and we also heard today that 23 and 24
year olds um
harry will be invited to to pick up
their jab from tomorrow
and we also had questions and this is
the beginning of the argument shaping up
on whether or not you should vaccinate
children
and previously we'd heard that in
smallpox for example
you vaccinated children to save children
the problem with covet is you vaccinate
children to save
adults and that makes it morally harder
to justify
unless you look at this other argument
which is what the telegraph's picked up
which is
you do it to keep their to keep them in
classes
yeah i mean this has been sort of
rumbling below the below the scenes for
a little while but as you
so rightly say the closer we get to you
know that july 19th date of
all adults being vaccinated the sort of
pressure to keep going if we have got
supply i think it's gonna get very
very loud especially if we sort of get
through to the school holidays
and cases are dropped perhaps you know
lifts um some of the scientists say
actually
there'll be a natural dip in in uh
transmission when the schools break up
anyway
just because you're breaking up those
those large gatherings and whether it's
yeah as a telegrapher sort of
getting um getting a sniff off is what
happens when it's for kids to go back to
school in september what happens
if we're having arguments in these
issues in the middle of the height of
summer
about the indian variant cases going up
what's it gonna be like in uh
in a rainy rainy november and the snowy
december
um so i think i suspect we'll end up
in a sort of situation where no one will
be
forced to have it but i think it will
certainly be available to children
yeah very very quickly pippa your
thoughts on that
well as somebody who has one of my
children
between july last year and march this
year was actually only in school for six
weeks because of self-isolation
because of obviously cases in the class
i can definitely see
the advantages um for not interrupting
their schooling and that being a reason
which i think many parents would support
when it comes to vaccinating their kids
but this is the obviously safety of
issues there as well
and also concerns and parents will want
reassurance on those before they
they agree to it yeah well that's bad
isn't it six weeks
you poor thing you your poor child as
well very very tricky
um safety is key we heard from professor
witte luckily other countries are doing
it before us so you've got real world
data
to look at about that crucial safety
question but lots for parents to
consider as we
as we go on through the months lots more
so to come
including a look at this story in the ft
nato's warning
against china's military ambitions
discussing that in just a moment
[Music]
welcome back watching the press preview
with me now pippa career and harry cole
both of you back from
cornwall uh and the g7 obviously we've
already had the nato meetings we'll come
on to that in a minute but let's go to
the metro first of all
uh joe biden it says urge boris johnson
to protect
the northern ireland peace process in a
candid private face-to-face meeting
during the g7 summit it has been
revealed um
yes go on then harry you're laughing
yeah i mean this was the story that was
meant to be the big thing that was gonna
blow up boris's
uh you know first face-to-face meeting
with biden
it was gonna be a big showdown it was
gonna be everything and it sort of it
sort of fizzled out a little bit and
then
bravo to the metro for trying to you
know revive it but
down the street we're pretty pleased
with how the how the biden meeting went
they're pretty pleased with how the g7
went
and frankly having a round with the
french doesn't tend to do
a tory politician's um poll rating that
uh that
that big a dent uh now classic bat
is sort of rolled onto brussels now with
um buck biden
you know visiting he popped in to see
the queen for tea um broke all sort of
normal
diplomatic protocol of discussing with
american press pack what he talked about
the queen with
and then rolled into old into brussels
to his first meeting at nato
now biggest contrast of of the last few
years is just how normal these things
have been
the g7 there was no you know the u.s
presidents throw starbursts to angela
merkel like donald trump did
he actually signed the communique he
turned up to
nato and didn't threaten to pull the us
out of it
just think the trump era really is just
being slowly
you know etched from the angles of
history by
by by and i think that's that's sort of
fascinating to watch um sort of the
unstitching of uh of what we're for very
turbulent atlantic is but it has to say
it made the summit so it looks
fun to come to cover yes i bet it did
and uh
obviously the big issue on the front
page of the ft
and indeed in that metro article we saw
too um in the last minute of our program
pippa is china a major security risk
according to nato
yes and the us wants to make sure that
nato as well as the
the g7 take a more robust line against
um
china which hasn't obviously been
traditionally seen as much of an
opponent as
as russia and later leaders in that
communicator harry perry
mentioned and warned about the systemic
challenges um
that china presents and and the need
therefore for for the leaders to take
very robust action and that is
everything from uh
you know it's sort of nuclear ambitions
to uh its presence in
in it's cyber warfares in cybersphere
um and uh you know big challenges ahead
there which they were trying to strike
sort of a consensual tone on um to use
obviously
more if the g if the if need to and then
do the g7 unit against china they're a
more powerful adversary aren't they
yep and on to that meeting with
president putin too so lots of
fascinating
days ahead no doubt for uh joe biden and
the rest of us